[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti che bello essere qua
in tanti in presenza sentire le energie
le voci vedere le sfumature dei volti
sorrisi sguardi su ucciso la salute
onestamente non ne possiamo più grazie a
questo invito
io ho seguito da tanti anni ed è lo
slogan di the ideas worth spreading idee
che hanno che meritano di essere
affrontate sintetizza molto bene perché
siamo qui oggi
oggi voglio raccontarvi un'idea che
ritengo importante e voglio raccontare
una storia che è avvenuta sotto i nostri
occhi senza che ce ne accorgessimo e
senza che decidessimo di fare qualcosa
di agire
amo molto questo neologismo omogenea
pochi giorni fa ero vicino inquadrato in
alto vedete l'averlo dhabi lasciandola
l'entrata c'è la meravigliosa frase di
terenzio homo sum humani a me alien è un
punto sono un uomo è niente di quelle
cose che riguarda l'uomo posso
considerarla estranea indifferente a
meno la storia che oggi voglio
raccontarvi è la storia del sud italia
degli ultimi 30 anni
una storia che straordinariamente
sorprendentemente a vista su celle fosse
ingeribile uniche senza che però noi e
credo che siamo un po tutti originari
del sud siamo tutti dalla campania credo
grande maggioranza di noi abbiamo avuto
voglia di reagire o voglia di capire
voglia di agire in maniera diversa
qual è la storia viola montana l'italia
è un paese del g7 del g8 non le prime 10
mila e punto sapete voi qual è tra le
prime dieci economie del mondo e tra le
prime 30 economie più sviluppate quindi
le prime 10 in termini dimensionali la
cina in stati uniti la russia italia
brasile la germania l'inghilterra la
francia è già in 35 paesi sviluppati
siamo europa nord america e l'asia ricca
quale l'unico care paese che abbia visto
svilupparsi e allargarsi un grande
spirito territoriale questo paese si
chiama l'italia l'italia
ha fatto un vero e proprio miracolo di
tale quel paese che aveva un'area
storicamente molto più povera del resto
del paese che si chiama il sud che dal
1950 quando una grande leadership
politica grandi pensatori uno stato che
decide di fare uno stato unitario
a fronte del problema aveva un ritardo
lo il sud che possiamo esprimere
metterlo insieme tanti indicatori da
quelli economici
il reddito pro capite a quelli sociali
la mortalità infantile l'analfabetismo
l'abbandono scolastico
facciamo un grande calderone e diciamo
che ritardo nel 1950 era cento dal 1950
1990 in ritardo era stato in gran parte
superato diciamo che il sud italia nel
1990 era arrivato a circa 78 quindi il
delta si era ridotto ma importante due
terzi del the stairs aveva sentito nei
40 anni dal 1950 1990 due terzi del
ritardo in sud italia rispetto al resto
d'italia erano stati superati grazie
alla cassa del mezzogiorno grazie certo
80 spesa pubblica consociativa e
assistenziale però il sud che era nel 50
ancora in larga parte semi analfabeta
molto povero agricolo abbia scoperto il
turismo abbiamo avuto
industrializzazione aveva avuto
l'infrastruttura infrastrutturazione che
ha fatto dei grandissimi passi per cui
la vita la più giusta qualità del regio
evocabile delle speranze di fare una
vita agiata
erano molto simili nel sud rispettare
sfruttare dopo di che cosa è successo
non è che ci siamo
all'improvviso di mendicanti e come
collettività come comunità
la bella parola comunità avevamo bisogno
di fare ancora un però lo sforzo per
raggiungere il resto d'italia ed è
successo questo che orami vi dico nel
1990 la germania est era un paese molto
povero la germania est quando il grande
polo e decise che non importava il costo
la germania e doveva essere riunificata
e alla gente che diceva un cancelliere
ma quanto ci costa non importa il mio
sogno da quando sono un ragazzo che
divide la germania unita
e voglio morire in una germana unità né
la germania est aveva un reddito pro
capite il 44 per cento rispetto alla
germania dell'ovest
quindi era ricca meno della metà per la
germania ovest e la germania prese molto
sul serio questa sfida comincia questi
recenti accetto miliardi all'anno le
infrastrutture informazione in processi
di riconversione nel 2018
la germania aveva circa il 77 per cento
delle due pro capite dell'arresto la
germania
vediamo questo film in italia nel 1990
mi dicevo i verdi e probabile delle
sonde nel 74 per cento rispetto al
reddito pro capite del resto d'italia
senza il sogno molto simile ad una
germania ma noi che siamo dei geni
questi 30 anni invece di guadagnare quei
26 punti che mancavano le ho perso
altrimenti tutti nel 2019 e frumento
meno intenda mezzo il sud italia c'è un
reddito pro capite che circa il 55 per
cento del totale
abbiamo accumulato ben di punti dei dati
eravamo in ritardo
abbiamo assunto altri 20 punti ritardo
abbiamo perso albumina un milione
giovani laureati
abbiamo voluto subito la vergogna della
totale assenza di investimenti
infrastrutturali per trent'anni come se
fosse facilissimo accettato e
assolutamente normale e cittadino il
sotto sono cittadini di serie b
era normale che la nascono investisse
assume perché c'è la mafia perché loro
grafia complicata era normale che le
ferrovie non immessi si assume come se
fosse un castigo divino e sorprendente
che noi cittadini del sud
abbiamo accettato senza voce senza dire
niente
poi c'è forse ho fatto ineluttabile noi
abbiamo avuto un altro fenomeno che si
chiamava calderoli
che invece una legge che era sulla carta
una buona legge la famosa io dico fa
vincerà la legge calderoli questa legge
calderoli cosa diceva che la spesa
pubblica corrente dimentichiamo gli
investimenti parliamo di quello che
serve per gli asili negli ospedali per
tutte le cose che rendono la vita civile
di una comunità accettabile anche per i
cittadini meno abbienti non si posso
permette di pagare tutte queste cose
l'allocazione dei soldi avveniva su tre
criteri primo che tellus spesa storica
spento cento l'anno scorso e l'anno
prossimo voglio spendere qualcosa di
simile ed ero ragioneremo con altre due
fattori il fattore si chiamava i livelli
essenziali delle prestazioni
qual è il numero degli asili nido per
ogni 1000 bambini cui ha diritto
una pulita indipendentemente se abiti a
reggio calabria 9 reggio emilia a
bergamo a matera o a salerno e poi un
fondo perequativo le comunità più ricche
dovevo contribuire per far sì che le
unità meno ricche avessero accesso a dei
livelli comparabili non uguali
comparabili e prestazioni sociali alle
giocate non rientra vigore subito con un
blitz della lega e del governo
dell'epoca ci disse non aspettiamo di
metterci sia partiamo subito tanto
queste cose fanno su cui leggo passati
12 anni
non esistono ancora i livelli essenziali
di prestazioni e il fondo perequativo
non è ancora attivo il risultato sotto
gli occhi di tutti è che mentre
sull'economia siamo a un rapporto di uno
a 250 per 155 sugli indicatori di
welfare rapporto 1 a 10 1 appetiti i
bambini della calabria hanno accesso
alle mense scolastiche un ventesimo dei
bambini delle medie
quindi non è più un dato comparabile
perché c'è l'economia dire che siamo
lenti la medaglia e un gigantesco
divario che forse scopriremo nelle
prossime tre generazioni
se ne va avanti così l'allargamento
continua ma a dire che i rapporti un
artigiano avventura roba che grida
vendetta il sud dovrebbe stare con le
molotov e le barricate
all una mobilitazione sui cittadini
esasperata invece diamo tutto questo
titolo è scontato e spesso che lo
sappiamo chi vi parla all imprenditori e
manager ha passato ho 16 anni la mia
vita all'estero solo si rimbocca le
maniche ho costruito aziende che danno
da lavorare a circa i minori persone
quasi tutte al sud
quindi non c'è niente di più lontano da
me del piagnisteo mini di una lista del
revanscismo neoborbonico non dobbiamo
rimboccarci le maniche come pulita ma
dobbiamo capire quello che sta avvenendo
dobbiamo capire ai fatti e rimboccarsi
le maniche anche per pretendere quelli
che sono i nostri diritti quando dico la
voce del sud sotto non ho avuto voce in
questi anni addirittura in questi anni
gli urti guardi solo il passare una
legge sul federalismo rafforzato che
dicevo sostanzialmente lo dico
napoletano che ha avuto ha avuto chi ha
dato ha dato il federalismo
differenziale significa che meno
facciamo la foto fischiava adesso e
rimaniamo così ecco questa è una
ulteriore mostruosa gigantesca
ingiustizia e abbiamo 400 comuni del sud
che per molti anni hanno avuto
fabbisogno 0 sugli asili nido per
bambini c'erano vorrei ma vincerà
giuliano in campania nordinapoli più
grande comune d'italia non capoluogo di
provincia già quasi gli abitanti di
salerno ha avuto per sei anni fabbisogno
a zero sugli asili nido i bambini
giuliano ne sono migliaia non avevano
gli stessi diritti ma non dico stessi ma
almeno la metà ci accontentiamo di un
terzo vabbè facciamo invece non avevano
stessi diritti di un decimo e bambini di
bergamo di vincere con questo è quello
che è successo nel totale disinteresse
di noi meridionali
ripeto piagnisteo no questa cosa
significa che dobbiamo prendere
coscienza rimboccarci le maniche
pretende nostri diritti e poi fare la
nostra parte perché quando ti dicono sì
ma il solo spende i dati ebbene sì ma
gli sprechi
ma la camorra tutto vero però sono stati
anche un grande alinghi faccio un'altra
domanda
sapete qual è l'unico paese del mondo
dove c'è un tratto di mare di 3 km 5
mila abitanti oltre tre chilometri e non
c'è fonte l'unico tutto il mondo italia
il ponte sullo stretto di messina in un
paese civile sarebbe fatto 50 anni fa e
non si poneva proprio il tema se farlo
non farlo se ci sono gli abitanti è
vecchio per i magi con porte e basta la
svezia e la danimarca sono stati in
guerra per secoli hanno fatto un forte
di 18 km un mare molto più tempestoso
molto più pericoloso molto più
complicato del nostro stretto di messina
con questo per dire che il pregiudizio
anti milionario abbiamo introiettato
siamo noi quasi a dire mai sentitamente
ponte sullo stretto mc o mai più
importanti ma certo ci sono sempre in
ogni momento cose più urgenti da fare
che non fare il ponte suo assetto ma il
fatto che siamo qui e dopo 70 anni non
abbiamo fatto la prova che noi stessi
milionari
abbiamo introiettato così c'è in
psicologia un pregiudizio su fatto che
se in fondo
ora che ci mettiamo tanto quindi
accontentiamoci di salvare dove stesse
nostre famiglie piuttosto che ragionare
come comunità che ha degli interessi e
delle ammissioni e che vuole ricostruire
e fa molto piacere parlare oggi è detto
perché questo è un esempio di cose
meravigliose grandiose che possiamo fare
anche al sud
zaha hadid donna straordinaria contro
l'onore e il piacere di conoscere bene
uno stato diverse volte con lei è stata
tolta che a casa sua nuovo gran donna
straordinaria brillante intelligente
conta aveva una scelta
nella ripresa purtroppo nerissimi nativa
dell'iraq vada da sempre ha allora
avevamo un seme un grande amico comune
iracheno zaha hadid la sua ultima opera
è stato questa insieme alla stazione di
afragola che ho avuto l'onore di
costruire la presidente all'età ferro e
diceva sempre che il sud è una
straordinaria unica perla nell'italia e
che è spiegabile per lei come ancora si
sa così poco sviluppato io ho scritto un
libro che siamo al sodo perché no che ho
presentato anche in questo meraviglioso
luogo esattamente tre anni fa e questo
libro l'ho scritto perché sa che non ne
ho mai messo a fuoco questa profonda
gigantesche giustezza del sud ha subito
senza voce ma ora dobbiamo dare la voce
la somma è una porta ero a napoli e
portai a visitare napoli per tre giorni
la più grande business man del mondo
mark insomma fondatore è andato in più è
la più grande agenzia di pubblicità e
comunicazione del mondo mio grande amico
e noi venne da me 74 giorni come a
napoli lo portai a fare di tutto lo
stadio le catacombe la sanità e qualche
spagnolo è un pacs e gli raccontai tutti
i dati che descrivono ridato il sud è
una sera in un lunedì notte con una cena
aperitivo
la bassa caffè amaro erano cosi più
brillanti e mi disse questa frase mi
colpì con un pugno dico sempre è bella
di bering lese vite questi dati assurdi
del ritardo e sulle già allargata con
l'italia che non faceva niente che mi
disse questa frase adornando stem cells
calcio aiac set
non capisco un paese civile nei colpi
paese civile noi siamo l'italia
cosa c'è di più civile l'italia abbiamo
700 un paese civile o ancellare civile
accettare quello disse non voglio più
accettarlo nel mio piccolo fanno tutto
quello che posso per fare sentire la mia
voce è scritto questo libro fonda tante
volte anche televisore questa cosa
ripeto noi dobbiamo come sud prendere
coscienza di questo straordinario
fenomeno unico dei paesi sviluppati
unico appunto per ribellarci ma norma
urlando che sono cattivi rimboccandoci
le maniche pretendendo quello che il
nostro mobilitandoci facendo sentire la
nostra voce ma non per il piagnisteo che
detesto più dei mandati varese ma con le
proposte territorio bellezza turismo
intelligenza artificiale innovazione
forse del genere questa nostra forza da
lì possiamo dobbiamo ripartire però
dobbiamo farlo adesso è che da dieci
anni la demografia ci ha dato il colpo
di grazia aveva messo tanti giovani
tanti talenti
se perdiamo anche voi vedo tanti giovani
in cui siamo uno dico francese i fottuti
quindi o ci diamo da fare adesso o da
dieci anni sarà troppo tardi
ma quello guarda 5 secondi
ci tenevo a condividere questa idea
un'idea non eri lamentazione e di
vittimismo ma l'idea di ottimismo di
voglia di fare di voglio ripartire con
la coscienza che abbiamo subito stiamo
subendo nella giustizia è colpa nostra
perché non ci siamo mobilitati
organizzati e fatti sentire la voce
subito siete voi siamo noi e non
possiamo dimenticare che la storia ci
giudicherà media molto severa se saremo
noi che abbiamo sotto i nostri occhi
senza aver mosso un dito assistito
inermi alla morte in su
non possiamo permetterci grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]